Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming to my session today.
I really appreciate it.
Uh, I'm James Chatmus,
Principal Solutions Engineer at Octopus
Deploy.
Genuinely excited to be here today.
Uh, today we're diving into a challenge
that every bank on the planet
is wrestling with.
How do I deploy software faster?
Without breaking compliance
and without failing my audit.
My session is all about building CICD
pipelines that are both genuinely
fast and 100% compliant,
which is a true North Star that most banks
are looking towards, uh, in
this current
day and age.
In my role at Octopus Deploy, I work with
some of the largest banks in the world,
helping them automate their CICD
pipelines.
So everything that we're going to be looking at today
is based on patterns that I've seen
time and time again.
All right.
Great. All right, so
here's the game plan for the next 18 minutes.
Uh, we're gonna start by talking about
why supply chain attacks are the number
one risk for banks in 2025,
uh, and why all
automated software delivery pipelines are susceptible
to them. Uh, then I'll fire
up a live demo.
Uh, I'll walk you through a true
zero trust.
Deployment pipeline end to end
uh using GitHub actions and Octopus Deploy,
which is the exact pattern
that a lot of banks are moving towards
uh to deploy their production workloads.
And then finally, uh, we'll look at how
Octopus deploy enforces governance
around things like verifying attestations,
uh, checking S-bombs, and validating
vulnerabilities at deploy time.
So let's
set the stage with a statistic that's
uh pretty eye-opening.
75% of enterprise
organizations, that's 3 out of 4,
have experienced some sort of supply chain
attack in the past 12 months.
Pretty wild, right? Um,
and I mean if I'm an attacker, it
kind of makes sense.
I could spend time trying to, you know,
hack into a hardened production
environment.
But why would I do that? Why wouldn't I just
slip some malicious code into the CICD
pipeline and let my target just deploy
it out to production themselves?
And what if you're a bank or a
payments processing company or some
other regulated financial
institution, uh,
all of a sudden that malicious code that makes it
out into production
could turn into eight-figure fines for your
company, uh, could turn into your
CISO or CEO on the evening news.
Not a great look.
So that's exactly why supply chain security
has
quickly bubbled up to the top of the list
of priorities for organizations
over the past 12 months.
So let's talk about the true reality
of modern.
Pipelines
You kick off a build,
uh, your unit tests run,
uh, you code scan your repo,
uh,
your artifacts get created, get pushed
out to your package repository,
uh,
and you're ready to deploy, and then
nothing.
The artifact just sits there,
you know, sometimes for hours,
sometimes for days,
uh, and in a lot of the companies that I've
spoken with recently,
uh, those artifacts just sit there for weeks
before they get deployed.
And that time gap between the build
and the deploy,
uh, that's called the drift window or
as I like to call it, that's the danger zone.
And a lot of things can happen in there,
um.
Anything from a configuration
drift,
uh, you could have a new zero
day published, or
in the worst case scenario, a
bad actor decides to
replace the artifact with one that has
malicious code in it.
Point being, the longer that drift window
exists, the bigger the blast radius,
uh, for any sort of changes.
The scary part though, is that most
organizations
have multiple drift windows within
any release cycle.
So, uh, you know, you've deployed to
dev, you're waiting for your QA
team to promote it out to their environment
before they can test it, could be a few days.
Maybe you've made it to your stage environment, but
you're waiting on cab approval to go to
production. That could be weeks, uh.
And I've worked with some companies
that get everything approved, they're ready to deploy
to production,
but they only do deployments once
per quarter, so you're sitting around, that
artifact is just sitting there essentially going
stale, uh,
during that drift window,
um.
So how do we make that drift
window something that's safe and, and
not something that's, uh,
a constant risk as when
it exists?
So we can make that safe with,
uh, by putting together three
key
pieces
that work in harmony to kind of.
Make that drift window safer.
The first one, software bill of materials.
You might have heard the term S-bomb.
This is the ingredient list of what went
into building
our artifact. So
it's a complete list of the third party
libraries and components that were used to
create the application.
The second piece is our provenance.
So this is the who, what, when, where and
how of that artifact
getting created.
Um, so everything from the commits
that are in it
to the, the workflow file
that was used to build it
to, uh, the runner that
the build was run on, uh,
everything around the creation of that artifact
is the Province, and then finally
the third piece is our attestation.
This is the, the cryptographic glue
that kind of holds everything together.
It's a signed statement or a certificate,
uh. That's saying, hey,
this S-bomb belongs
to the package that I created,
and this is the provenance that was used
to create it.
And ideally, all three of these
are generated automatically,
uh, and they're
verified at each stage of your
software delivery life cycle.
When these three work together in unison,
that's how you get a drift window,
uh, that doesn't rely on luck
to be safe. Uh, you're putting controls
in place to, to make it a
safe time.
So the Zero Trust pipeline only
works with a clear separation of duties
and a clear segregation
of responsibilities.
Um, so let's talk about who
does what.
On the left we have GitHub,
uh, exactly where it should be with
our code, uh, and that's
doing everything on the CI side of the house.
So, uh, we're building our code,
running our unit tests and scans,
generating our S-bomb and attestations,
scanning for vulnerabilities, and then ultimately
we're publishing our artifacts out to
our package repository, that
immutable artifacts.
Once the CI process is
complete,
uh, that's when Octopus
comes into play.
Now think of Octopus deploy as
your, uh,
single source of truth for everything deployment
related and kind of the final
gatekeeper when it comes to,
uh, deploying your
applications safely.
So octopus, what are you responsible for?
Verifying our S-bomb,
validating our attestations?
Enforcing any sort of policies
that your organization has,
uh, maybe around approvals
or vulnerability checks or
uh configuration drift.
Once those quality gates pass,
then Octopus carries on with the
rest of the deployment process out
to EKS or ECS
or,
you know, serverless, EC-2s, what
have you.
Um, on top of that, we kind of keep,
uh, a rolling audit of
everything that's happened, uh, leading up to the
deployment, uh, and Octopus makes
it easy to roll back when
necessary. Perfect.
Slides are done.
Uh, I've got a real pipeline
ready to roll here.
Uh, let's fire it off real quick and watch this
whole, uh, zero
trust flow in action.
Perfect. So
we're gonna start uh in
GitHub where our code lives.
Uh, the project that we're gonna be working with
today is our account registry
project. Um, it's a containerized
application that we're deploying out to EKS.
So I'll hop open, I'll hop over
to my actions tab
and
uh
We have 2
actions workflows ready. Uh, so
we're gonna be focused on the supply chain,
verified, build pipeline,
GitHub actions workflow. So I'm gonna click
on it.
Uh, this workflow is doing a
ton behind the scenes, and I'll kind of walk you
through that, but let's, let's kick it off and,
uh, get it going.
So we'll run the workflow, refresh
the page,
and take a look at this, uh,
this GitHub action
in action.
I'm not gonna walk through the YAML file, not a lot of
value there,
uh, but we will kind of look at this, uh,
GitHub graph around what's happening. So,
first piece to point out,
this pipeline's built for speed, right? We're
not, uh, we're trying to deploy software
faster while keeping it safe.
Um, after our pipeline initialization,
uh, we're running a couple of steps in parallel.
So we're scanning our repo,
uh, at the same time that we're building our image,
uh, and publishing our S-bomb.
So that, that repost
scan is a quality
gate that takes about 20 seconds,
not a huge time sync,
but it's running in parallel with our
docker container build anyway. So we're
not losing anything in our total
time, uh, of
the workflow running.
We're also building our container, we're scanning
it, uh, and we're publishing that S-bomb,
that list of ingredients, uh, that we'll
use later in the deployment process.
Once both of those quality gates pass,
uh, we're publishing our GitHub release,
uh, and then
we're signing and generating our attestation.
Uh, on the CI side of things,
this is kind of the, the critical
piece of this workflow.
So, uh, when we're signing and
generating the attestation,
uh, we're tying that S-bomb
and
uh our Docker container together,
uh, and we're essentially
getting signed metadata that
we'll use in the deployment process
to validate, hey.
The container that I'm about to deploy is the
exact one that I built earlier
in my, uh, pipeline.
And then finally,
uh, back to that separation of duties that we
talked about, uh, this is where we're handing
off the deployment to Octopus Deploy,
uh, to kind of continue with the CD
part of our CD CICD pipeline.
So let's hop over to Octopus now and,
and see what that looks like. So this is
the Octopus deployed dashboard for those
of you that haven't seen it.
Uh, it's a single control
plane, kind of like your air traffic control
tower for everything deployment related,
uh, in your organization.
We have a list of our projects
or our applications, our
services down the left side,
our environments across the top, and we
can see exactly
which version has been deployed out to
which environment.
So as you can see,
our uh account registry
project uh has already
started deploying to development that happened automatically
at the end of our GitHub actions workflow.
So I'm gonna click on,
click on this deployment, uh, and
it's gonna bring me to our task
log.
We'll take a look at the task summary screen.
So, there's a lot going on
as far as the Kubernete's deployment is
concerned, but,
uh, as far as
this presentation
is concerned, we're going to focus on the 1st 4
steps and how they relate to the zero
Trust pipeline.
So, uh, step one, we're
grabbing our packages, we're grabbing our S-bomb,
uh, grabbing our build information from GitHub
and, and kind of gathering that all
together for the subsequent steps.
Uh, step two,
we're verifying that S-bomb,
so we're looking through that list of ingredients,
uh, and cross-checking it
with what was in GitHub.
We're making sure that none of those ingredients have
changed, uh, and that, that software,
that software bill of materials is
still sound.
Now step 3,
talked about that critical stage in our GitHub actions
workflow.
This is that critical stage in our
deployment process.
So we are
taking
Our S-bomb, we're taking our container,
we're calculating
the SH 256 hashes
for each of those,
and then we're comparing them to what GitHub
says they should be in the Adi station.
If they match, uh, we know that the
container that we're about to deploy
is the exact one
that we built. Uh, if there is something
off between them, we know that there's been some
sort of tampering along the way
in our pipeline.
So I've mentioned attestations a few times.
Quick detour back to GitHub,
uh, and if we scroll down a little bit,
uh, for those of you,
of you that haven't seen,
uh, GitHub Advanced Security,
uh, we'll take a quick look at our attestation,
uh. Real
quick, so
top section, uh, we have our
provenance. Remember this is all the build
information, our commits, our workflow
file, so on and so forth.
Uh, the middle section has a number
of, uh, certificate keys
that are used to, to verify,
uh, but.
The key of this
attestation that we're working with
are subjects down at the bottom. So you can
see our Docker container in
our S-bomb file
along with their subject digest.
So when we calculate those in octopus, we're
comparing those to these values and
making sure that they match.
And then finally, step 4,
we're checking GitHub for open vulnerabilities
using the GitHub API.
Doesn't make a ton of sense on this automatic
deployment to development because we just
built it, you know, 3.5 minutes
ago, but if you remember that drift
window maybe that artifact's been
sitting there for 3 or 4 weeks.
Always a good idea to do a final scan,
uh, of our repo to make sure nothing's
been published, no 0 days exist,
uh, no vulnerabilities have
made their way into what we're about to
send out to our production environment.
From there, uh, we're kind of
continuing with the standard Kubernetes
deployment, creating our name space,
config maps, so on and so forth.
So that's what that zero trust pipeline
looks like.
Uh, a few other pieces that I'll, I'll key
in on just, uh, when we're talking about
deployments for regulated industries.
Uh, you notice this top,
uh, steps says apply compliance
policies. I clicked on that.
Um, in Octopus, we have the ability
to, uh, define.
Policies using Rego
uh that span across your entire
instance. So, uh, this allows
platform teams to
standardize,
uh.
The governance around all deployments
in their organization and
uh create standards, uh,
for any deployment that goes out.
Other piece that we'll key in on
is our Kubernetes tab over
here uh in the upper right. So,
uh, we're deploying to EKS,
uh, and at deploy time,
Octopus is
pulling back a snapshot of
all the different Kubernetes objects that
are getting deployed.
Along with their status,
uh, so,
uh, first off, if any of these were unhealthy,
we would see that here in our, our
object status screen,
uh, but as a developer, maybe I don't have
access to direct access to
my cluster. This is a great way for
me to figure out, hey, what is going on
in my cluster, uh, without having
to get into the, uh,
you know, the hardened environment or without
having to give out access to,
uh. To a wide array
of people.
Last piece we'll look at is our build
information. So we're pushing this build information
to
Octopus from GitHub,
and it's kind of a, a,
a sanity check, an extra length
that goes back to our build, uh, where
we can get at, uh, those S-bomb
files, our attestations,
uh, our provenance, and so on and so forth.
So back to the dashboard, uh,
That's our zero trust pipeline,
uh. Signed by
GitHub and verified and deployed
with governance through Octopus
Deeploy.
Head back here.
So, Kind of
things, uh, what did we
accomplish today?
Um, we established a chain of
trust from build to deploy.
Uh, GitHub generated the S-bomb, the Provenance,
and the attestation, uh, and Octopus
verified all of those before
anything was deployed.
Second, we enforce deployment governance.
Uh, so, uh, our deployment
went through policy evaluation,
it went through vulnerability checks, it
went through
validation of the attestation. Uh,
all these controls are
exactly what. Uh, regulated
financial organizations need when deploying
out to production,
uh, and then finally we verified our artifact
integrity. Um, we verified
that the artifacts that we deployed were the exact
ones that we built, uh, and
that they hadn't been tampered with.
So thank you for coming out. I, I really appreciate
you. 5 o'clock, end of the first day.
Thanks for coming out and joining me.
Uh, again, we're at booth 678,
kind of right
there, right in front of Q Qualcomm.
Happy to, uh, chat with you, answer
any questions, uh, yeah, and
continue the conversation. Thanks so much.